hello everyone i'm alana and i am
very excited to be playing the first
hour of straight today huge thank you to
annapurna interactive for giving me a
code this is one of my most anticipated
games of the year i'm so so so excited
we're playing on a ps5 today and this is
my first time playing i don't know what
we're in for but i can't wait to find
out so
let's do it
curious to see like
someone mentioned the game being open
world i wasn't sure i felt about that so
what is the world like how many puzzles
are there
what's the gameplay how much of it is
stealth a lot of questions
i believe the cat's name is winston so
also just excited to meet winston and
somebody who's very allergic to cats
i hope i can at least bond with the
digital cat
it's already
very cute
hello buddy
oh my gosh
we don't deserve video games
oh my gosh
i wonder how much they
like studied
cats to get those animations right
oh i'm very impressed by the the rigging
3d model of a cat is one thing
3d model of a cat that like moves its
arms like a cat actually does
my my
oh my god the purring
the jewel sounds vibrating
i'm gonna just jump down here bud
you're a cat you hate rain you could
never
oh it's not
oh i feel like something bad's gonna
happen
i'm scared hold me
[Music]
you're not on the cardboard anymore but
[Music]
this is so cute what the hell
[Music]
inside the wall
i'm already very interested in the world
building like
how is it gonna dull out information i i
expect
you can't have a lot of exposition where
presumably there is no
dialogue from your protagonist
[Music]
[Music]
some of those animations look a little
bit more stiff but also that's because
this is leaning into gameplay so
it is what it is
who cares
i really want a jump button i keep
pressing x like i should be able to jump
[Music]
circle is meow
[Music]
make me out back
oh my gosh okay it doesn't appear to be
any run that's a zoom so that's for
stealth stuff probably okay run is r2
that feels great
um
probably not gonna want to do that
it's x to jump
can't climb mouse okay
it's nuts how quickly
i already know anything like this um
makes me think of the last of us like
they really
got such a hold on that aesthetic
the video games at least
i really want to explore but i know it's
not
they waited for each other how
uncat-like oh my gosh
[Laughter]
[Music]
very good very good they thought of it
all
[Music]
drink good stuff good stuff
this makes me miss rain living in l.a
let me tell you it
does not rain out here and i came from
the tropics i'm born in a city called
cairns in australia
i grew up with cyclones
it was a rainy
i miss it all the time
sucks that it's so dry
it certainly stuck to the environment
too
oh the purring is killing me i feel like
this game is going to make me sleepy
somebody chased away some birds
[Music]
it doesn't i keep looking around
expecting that to be collectibles but at
this stage i'm not suspecting there are
any
by the looks of things
uh-huh i see cool
it's neat that it's showing me um that's
an interesting tutorialization choice
obviously we have big text on screen
but that it's showing me the other cats
doing things in front of me so that i'll
be like oh that's what i'm supposed to
be doing
it's a good choice
like because they can't talk to me about
it
i don't speak me out
i see platform
let's go
oh cat's too light to weigh it down oh
no
oh no winston i think is your name
what
buddy
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i want to make you so sad
oh god
oh the echoed me house oh
god
okay
dude you didn't have to do me oh he's so
big
oh somebody who fosters animals let me
tell you
every single one of them has had a
medical issue
my current foster dog
has a limp it's hitting me extra hard
like i feel personally responsible
for that thing i didn't even do
i feel like they probably intentionally
took uh
control away from the player for that
because then it would just like feel
like a lot more like your own failures
than you passively experienced oh god
what were those
was was that a head crab
is this actually half-life 3.
come on you okay yeah you're okay
you cannot cat
i like the design of this tunnel
you can see the concept art
cool
okay
there's like a hum coming from here
hmm
dead city huh
okay what are they
i do not know
[Music]
um
[Music]
they look like little pokemon but like
objectively evil oh is this a
robot corpse
there's anything else i can glean from
street art or posters
clearly all a different language
pandemic protocol
do not try to exit the city avoid any
contact with other residents violating
the rules of confinement will result in
a heavy prison sentence okay so there
was some sort of
pandemic
is there any other
don't appear to be another one though
that's it
for instructions
walt city99.com i would love to go to
that see if there's actually anything on
there
um okay so we're in a walled city i
suppose
and i don't know if this is presumed to
be a dead area or if people are just
asleep still has power obviously i'm
assuming the camera's government
surveillance rather than private
surveillance
personnel only
that's gonna relate to the
dead
corpse of the robot and no music huh
[Music]
it's very nice wow
okay
i like that great way of drawing my eye
to it too
[Music]
[Music]
the camera
wow i'm into this okay
cause like this game get was gonna hook
people based on the cute cat no matter
what right
you didn't have to do other cool stuff
of course i was hoping it would but they
didn't have to
oh
is that filling i can't tell
i'm sure but there are a number of them
so i'm sure i'm going to use it for
something
hmm
it is interesting to play a game as a
cat and be like well i can't open doors
so what do i need doors for
hmm
i suspect that trying to go through this
would kill me
but
okay good i was like hopefully they
don't give me that animation and instead
they just don't do it
confirmed okay so there's a puzzle down
here
i just don't know what it is somebody's
speaking to me
um is filling up
it doesn't look like it i don't know
what i can do with them
this just seems like the obvious thing
to do but it's probably not correct
is there some use for these out here
and i missed because i can go backwards
hmm does somebody need water
so if you can hear my dog parking i
don't know when he's [ __ ]
[Music]
i wonder
is that lead anywhere
let's see if i missed a means to climb
high but my guess is that i need to turn
the power off to get the band to stop
um
briefly have to disappear to check on
the dog um okay
oh success
that is what i thought would happen just
wanted to make sure that that was what
would happen
um i'm very into this kind of
i thought it was gonna let me push stuff
off ledges and then what it did
uh lack of tutorialization is very
appealing to me for sure
but i think this is interesting in that
it's like
what the game was doing to justify all
the
uh
pots
is that what you call those buckets
being there is having the drips that's
what it did to be like well these have
to be here for some reason so let's put
all these drips in it's interesting for
a player to be like okay well the drips
don't go in let me try the pot anyway
like to
choose which information goes to the
player in which uh which is world
building
it does imply that humans or some beings
were there trying to get those drips out
of that room though
come on bud
i want to see what it does
it's going so far down that it's not
splashing on anything
i want to see the paint
i want to see it
jump down here
pigeons huh
finally
i love it
is that me that just put all that paint
there or did another cat do that see
those little paws
oh i'm not sure
maybe it was another cat
oh this is exciting
how cool it's kind of creepy
again they could have just done
cute cat stuff but they've actually made
an interesting video game
yeah get it
men's socks
i wonder if uh
they're all
humans anywhere or if humans are gone i
i feel like we saw them in the trailers
but i don't honestly remember
um okay
[Applause]
very cute
zero four seven six two four six six
get back here
they just disappear into the walls how
annoying
i don't know what they are
they look like giant ticks which is
horrific
ugh
actually scared the [ __ ] out of me
was it you who pulled for me
oh
[Music]
you just like disable it
i don't feel great about that
[Music]
like in this song
[Music]
it's also um
sorry i know that like
now that i work in game development i
just
keep wanting to talk about game dev
stuff
but that light being on and yellow with
the up arrow was to like very clearly
indicate to the player that was the
direction that you're supposed to head
in without anybody telling you that even
though there are still
multiple things you can climb up so it's
like you could still climb up this if
you want to they don't just make it so
there is only one thing to do in the
environment but then turning that light
off when you go over it to tell you yes
this is the right way to go is again
just very good tutorialization for a
game that
has very little tutorialization slash
none and no dialogue
i'm um
sorry if this is just boring
light
is the easiest way to
uh light and lines are the easiest way
to guide players in the right direction
and i feel like they've done a really
good job
but i understand
most people probably just prefer
silly funny commentary about their cute
cats so i'm sorry for
indulging myself so much
let's go
oh i hate this oh no
they're all like takes all these like
pustules oh gosh
loving the music
[Music]
[Music]
loving the way the world looks
[Music]
mmm creepy
[Music]
i'm trying to make out what that's
saying and from what i can tell sort of
nothing
doesn't actually seem like it's a
human saying anything um
again this use of arrows but in
ways that make sense in the world like
that's just telling you there's a bar
downstairs but it's also telling the
player which direction to go in
it's cool
all right
can jump there
of course you can you can jump that far
you're a cat
all right all right
that sense of scale here is pretty
impressive too
look how big how far down
help
goddaggers look huge
these blue symbols mean
i want to see the odd book for this game
real bad
[Music]
it's kind of reminding me of remember me
um which was uh
[Music]
one of don't nod's first game
first game's if not the very first and i
don't remember
um
oh
that's interesting
it's uh meowing leads them to tell me
where to go um not that i know how to
get up there
[Music]
somewhere
get up higher
i must be not seeing something the
barrel's the only thing i can see that i
can get up on
i don't think i can climb up on that
that's so cool
um hmm what am i missing
barrel flip it anyway
[Music]
aha it rolls
nice
[Music]
i just really like looking around
even if it's not quite necessary
oh we're not going down there where i
came from maybe
[Music]
[Music]
who got a bike there
this way
are you sure i'm not supposed to jump
down here
[Music]
that sounded like navi like zelda
hey
this place is huge i wonder if everybody
actually is dead if dead city is literal
i should make my uh webcam just this way
to take up less screen space okay
[Music]
cool that yeah they're just controlling
the lights
very neat
tell me where to go
i'm excited to meet whoever this is
[Music]
i'm finding this extremely calming
this way
over here okay
up here
kind of see the world in a very
different way as a cat makes you think
i wonder how the robots died
and the city still has power so yeah
again i i have this like very good
habit i've developed of being able to
completely block out trailers like i
just don't remember them anymore did
that say annapurna
i think it's probably supposed to look
like annapurna
um
yeah i just i've i've developed that
ability after wanting to for a long time
where now i just don't remember what
video game trailers i've seen even look
like anymore
and so um
things feel very fresh to me all the
time
and i feel like there were alive people
in the trailer
[Music]
what if i don't want to drop it what if
i want to keep it
what if i think it's mine now and you
can shut up
the flat
the flat we've been in a few flats but
this is the flat oh
i don't think cats could do that but
okay
what if i just take a
nap what if i just nap on the bed
who would stop me
okay
need help
you need help
[Music]
[Laughter]
very good
body required for download body required
enter the door turn on find a body
that's really cute
okay
oh not that door different door
there is some english because things say
made in france there's men's socks
some of it's english
another power cable
okay drop that first one in the first
room right
assuming i have to go back and get it
there's another one up there how do i
get up there
hmm
that's
take how one
now
okay so it's possible there'll be
another one in this room
no i assume oh the door's closed
oh there must be then where is it
they're nodding at me
where is the last port
this isn't me i need it i don't know
let's try the lever again
seeing it they have like a big globby
bit on them right
rock
[Applause]
perspectives
there
nope
okay
okay
[Music]
i'm really enjoying this creepy vibe
which i did not expect
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
are we sure
[Music]
what did i knock out
your head
no
okay
this looks like a ball sack what is it
[Music]
oh it is just gonna give me like a drone
friend
cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
that's so well animated i love it
[Music]
[Music]
b12
good vitamins
okay
where are we going boss
[Music]
oh i did that so do i control the drone
as well
interesting
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god i love it look at him he hates
it sorry buddy
[Laughter]
hmm
you can rotate items
i wonder if that'll
[Music]
i like the flat
[Applause]
oh nice
cool
code
three seven four eight
i don't know what it's for but i saw a
code
this game is
very good so far oh there we go
three
seven four
eight
like the choice to have that be the
light and have it move in the organic
way that it does
might not light up a whole room like
like a certain players would enjoy but
um
very impressive in terms of
[Music]
i am loving this and would not at all be
surprised if this ends up being
genuinely
uh
you know we have to see more of the game
of course but um
some outlets came in the um
[Music]
i guess
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh i can translate stuff now
safe zone makes sense
[Music]
whatever that means
doesn't look very safe down here dude
a droid
the slums
hello
because you saw a cat
you jerk
who's gonna come for me
[Music]
music's great
these are all also droids or maybe it's
just how humans
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello
is there combat
[Music]
i'm a bit scared of that pole
[Music]
[Music]
oh great
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
just a little cat my friends just a
little cat nothing to worry about here
so
okay
[Music]
you just can't leave
huh
[Music]
so this is a little bit more open world
i'd like to meet you
[Music]
i'd assume people had tried to fix it
[Music]
same bro same jordan can relate
[Music]
only our ancestors can distinguish these
colors it said they once dominated the
world
green
oh i wonder how far in the future this
is
[Music]
the soft ones okay so humans are
gone and this is what they left behind
that tracks
natural light that leaked from a star
and landed at our feet this light caused
warmth and well-being in our ancestors
the sun oh yeah they haven't seen the
sun in a long time i guess down here
damn
um okay let's try to get up there shall
we
start
maybe that's here
or whatever they call it
you can see stars oh there's a fake
we're inside a dome or something huh
that's a shame
that's pretty
what are all the paint for i wonder
and should i knock some of it no no
uh
yellow side
um
okay
there's a little elevator thingy
so probably we need to go all the way
over that way got it okay
so we have to start
on this side and then go up and around
up over
yeah i think that's correct
still check things out in the meantime
ventilation power supply oh yeah i'm
going there
why not i'm a cat do what i want
[Music]
don't mind if i do
thank you
[Music]
this music is so good
[Laughter]
oh
very good very good
nice one okay jump down
are we good to go down
we jump
closer
what is this
oh memory uh-huh
i love these solid plants
i wonder if they need them
oxygen is pretty important for a lot of
stuff i guess
beautiful
wow
i really have given up huh
okay so i think i felt that we needed to
just look this way
hello
are the zerks the little
choose from metal yeah they must be the
little critters
and i think it was this pole i wanted to
kind of move across
so i guess my my goal is to just get
outside
um for now i don't know if that's the
goal of the whole game
but that's certainly the goal right now
oh that's already up there
okay
maybe i could have just come this way
the whole time and i just oh no no
and i just didn't
oops
i think i could have
i just didn't realize okay i'll go in
here
hello
painting of a human then
[Music]
uh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
okay
oh can i scroll the city has a
cylindrical shape of about 450 meters in
diameter there's a level above owls hmm
the city seems to have a ceiling if i
believe my books
a big blue sky is hidden behind
wow
nice plant nice plant nice plant i'm
very into house plants recently i have
32 of them
mostly thriving
[Music]
toy for cat
seems like tofu cat
[Laughter]
oh my god it's making me walk the wrong
way
it's making me walk the wrong way
because i can't see
oh my gosh that's so good
holy [ __ ]
oh sheet music
what
for why
huh
that's it i would love to read more of
the actual inside of it but that's fine
um okay
the light up there's
it could be nothing i suppose but
yeah i suppose it's not
i don't need to do anything else
what's that sheet music
what's this
maybe i could reveal something what do
you got back there
no just nice scratches for the paws
don't mind me snooping your apartment
dude
don't worry about it
i took a picture very much like that
in um vancouver
that's also just a jpeg
it's quite a nice apartment my friend
back home
a cow
[Music]
same picture
some nice plants dude all right let me
inspect your tv what's going on with the
tv i can just jump on it not expect it
all right is there anything else
yes
that's all i can show him right now
um i'm guessing that's all there is for
me to do in here
[Music]
[Music]
a live metallic
[Music]
do cats scratch doors is that a thing
[Music]
matches the one on the notebook
cool i was like i don't know where i'm
gonna go if i leave here but i guess
that answered him
thanks bud
thanks little robo buddy let's go
[Music]
it i love that they also justify that
it's not actually a system for cats it's
a system for the plants but
but i'll take it
[Applause]
dude this music rules
[Music]
[Music]
i'd like to know who this component was
like if i were to make music i would
love it if it sounded like this
looks like a police notebooks would be
[Applause]
everything was going according to plan
we managed to contact the
upper level before the transceiver went
down
they're in a place called midtown and
apparently it's controlled by some kind
of oppressive force
his eyes i know this look he will not
come with us
let's find the other notebooks okay
well i wonder if uh it's supposed to be
new york then i guess midtown's pretty
generic there are probably midtowns all
over the
world chaos
all right
other notebooks
where is the light leading me
um
i guess back to the room with the
ventilator shaft but i don't know what i
even found in there at this point
check out what's in this direction
my dudes my guys
[Music]
i'm trying to get down you feel me
what is up
we could show them
okay uh we could take a different
notebook back to the moment but i kind
of want to talk to the outsider and see
what he has to say about number two
i love my friend
[Music]
tell me about
[Music]
okay it i go back to momo with
clementine's notebook
is this a store
[Music]
don't have that
clothing
i guess i'll end up needing these things
but right now
[Music]
they all are everywhere really
oh i could ask b12 for advice
i'm just gonna go to the upper flats
all right back up we go don't mind if i
do
though i guess actually this is probably
a good point to leave it before i
uncover more of the upper flats and you
know i always try to give people like an
insight to what the game is and where
it's headed
uh with these rather than like a full
less play where i'd be spoiling the
whole game so
i love this so far i'm very into it i'm
gonna keep playing and she's not gonna
record it
um based on the embargo timing
i will have already had a video about my
impressions after playing the game for
longer up because this has to go up the
day after but um i'll probably stream
more of the game
i'm playing on ps5 and opponent gave me
the code
and yeah really really enjoying it so
far there's so many things that are so
quality that again like didn't
necessarily need to be because they had
so many people sold on cute cat game
so uh
definitely very impressed thank you all
for watching